have you ever tuned in to a pro stream
and wondered why does the game look so
weird it does look like sh as Gamers we
often look to build the beefiest rigs
imaginable spending thousands of dollars
on these top-of-the-line components but
why go through all that trouble just
make your game look like this uh 1280
960 yeah full screen stretched so
usually I have 1280 960 same as in CS go
uh 43 128 960 why you might be screaming
inside well running FPS games in a 4x3
aspect ratio and lower resolution is
extremely common for a lot of Pros
especially within the Cs Community aside
from pumping out some extra frames it
also makes view models look bigger which
might help you click heads easier the
tradeoff is that you sacrifice some of
your field of view however okay he's
going to get around
the 43